bonjour à tous
alors le titre en fait de la
présentation c'est le tout abonnement
c'était un petit peu un titre un peu
plus provocateur qu'on verra plus tard
dans la présentation est en fait
j'aimerais à ce titre ajoutée ou le
compléter en nylon le tout abonnement ou
vous l'avez nom d'une autre société
aujourd'hui j'aimerais en fait vous
convaincre que le tout abonnement est un
modèle de business d'avenir qui est en
train en fait de bouleverser petit à
petit notre société et qui a déjà en
fait bouleversé le monde de l'entreprise
alors qui suis-je pour parler en fait de
ce sujet qu'est ce qui m'a amené en fait
à traiter en fait de ce sujet dans ma
vie en fait professionnel je développe
des logiciels pour le grand public ou
pour les entreprises
l'un des principaux modèles de
commercialisation des logiciels c'est
l'abonnement vous n'allez plus à la fnac
ou dans d'autres
j'ai d'autres marches ont acheté une
boîte en carton dans lesquelles il ya un
dvd revenir chez vous ou dans
l'entreprise je le met le glisser dans
votre ordinateur d'installer tout ça
vous utilisez votre navigateur et vous
utilisez un service auquel vous avez
souscrit ont quelques clics en voulant
commercialiser mes précédents logiciel
j'ai cherché en fait des solutions pour
pouvoir faciliter cette gestion
d'abonnements et ce qui m'a conduit en
fait avec un associé en ont développé
une et de la proposer à tous ceux qui
souhaitent commercialiser notamment
leurs logiciels des services et des
produits au début nous étions en fait
concentrer uniquement sur la gestion des
abonnements pour les logiciels
et puis curieux curieux de nature on
s'est intéressé à la vente d'abonnements
pour des produits des services et puis
en fait dans tous les types de secteurs
d'activité aujourd'hui que pouvons-nous
ont consommé par abonnement que consomme
en ou par abonnement ou quels sont les
produits et les services qu'on peut
accéder via l'abonnement
alors quand j'observe des jeux j'aime
bien en fait catégoriser on peut après
catégoriser de différentes manières mais
en fait j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait trois
types d'abonnements de consommation
liées à l'abonnement
il y à des consommations qui sont dites
permanentes qui sont plutôt liés de
l'immatériel ou de l'accès à un service
c'est par exemple le cas l'électricité
de l'eau de la télé de l'internet les
films la musique désormais maintenant on
peut souscrire des abonnements pour
avoir des catalogues infinie donc ça
c'est la première catégorie comme ceux
des consommations permanente et les
consommations récurrentes là qui sont
plus liés du matériel c'est par exemple
je veux recevoir tout je sais pas tous
les mois des brosses à dents ou tous les
mois ou tous les deux mois
du papier toilette et tout plein
d'autres services comme ça qu'ils
existent ça peut être de l'alcool ça
peut être il ya vraiment plein de choses
qui existent comme ça il y avait une
dernière en fait qui était catégorique y
arriver il y a enfin qui existe depuis
un moment mais on va dire qu'il devient
visible depuis quelques temps c'est la
consommation de renouvellement la
consommation de renouvellement en fait
c'est des produits auxquels vous prenez
des abonnements et ça peut être des
meubles de l'électroménager du
multimédia des bijoux des vêtements
auquel en fait vous abonner ces services
là et ils vous livrent ces produits là
que vous pouvez interchanger au regard
du contrat d'abonnement vous avez signé
que vous pouvez rendre et résilié quand
vous voulez et donc là c'est une autre
type de consommation
alors au début en fait je vous ai parlé
de l'abonnement et de l'avènement de
nouveaux mais l'avènement en fait d'une
nouvelle société
en fait je suis persuadé que
l'abonnement et permet la génération la
création l'apparition de nouveaux
modèles de business on fait pour mieux
comprendre cet aspect là il ya un
exemple qui est assez flagrant dans
notre société
en fait c'est le le téléphone mobile
l'internet mobile si les opérateurs
n'avaient pas décidé de proposer leurs
services sous forme d'abonnement il
n'aurait jamais pu assurer les
investissements colossaux dans leur
infrastructure qui la foule pas lui
mettre en place pour qu'on dispose de ce
service là et ce qui fait que pour des
investissements de plusieurs milliards
nous on paye 20 25 30 près selon les
volumes de consommation de téléphone
mais on paye en fait quelque chose de
dérisoire et pour lequel on a
un appareil qui coûte extrêmement cher à
produire et on bénéficie d'un service
donc on fait l'abonnement permet à tout
le monde sur de nombreuses personnes de
pouvoir en fait bénéficier d'un service
à moindre frais tout en maîtrisant
globalement on fait le coup et ça c'est
un autre aspect en fait de l'abonnement
et qui est très important on fait dans
notre société actuelle
car au regard en fait des taux de
croissance on voit qu'en fait le pouvoir
d'achat chez nous soit ils stagnent
soit il soit il réduit donc il ya besoin
en fait de nouveaux modèles qui nous
permette de pouvoir consommer tout en
réduisant en fait nos dépenses et par
exemple vous tapez dans vous tapez dans
sur amazon tapié papier toilette vous
avez vous pouvez acheter du papier
toilette mais aussi vous propose de vous
abonner pour recevoir x rouleaux par
mois tous les deux mois tous les trois
mois tous les six mois et en fait si
vous vous inscrivez vous utiliser ils
vont en fait il vous faut en fait une
remise de 15% sur l'ensemble en fait de
toutes les commandes et livraisons que
vous allez avoir ce qui permet en gros
par cet engagement là et bien vous
indiquer en fait aux commerçants que
vous allez pas simplement acheté une
fois mais vous allez acheter une fois ce
produit là et donc il va pouvoir en
contrepartie ou réduire vos faire une
une remise sur sûr c'est sur ces prix là
après dans le même genre on peut par
exemple louer souscrire des abonnements
pour disposer en fait de jouer pour des
enfants fait quand on regarde les jouets
des enfants on leur achète un jouet
c'est un mois après ils ont grandi le
jouer les plus bon et tout ça en fait ya
des services qui existent ou en gros ont
souscrit on reçoit trois quatre cinq
jouer et qu'on peut en fait avec cet
abonnement on peut retourner le jouer
quand on veut ou s'il est cassé ou pour
pouvoir en disposer qui correspond à
l'âge en fait de notre enfant est offert
mesure noces millions ce qui permet en
fait de pouvoir lisser nos dépenses et
permettre en fait avoir un budget qui
s'étale sur la longueur et pas
simplement à des moments précis
d'acheter de gros volumes de
de jouer par convenu tout dépend chacun
fait ce qu il après coup en fait cette
notion fait de jouer fait référence en
fait un autre point une autre réflexion
que j'ai eu quand je me suis penché en
fait sur l'univers de désabonnement les
jouets en fait il nous appartiennent
plus dans le cade sur le souscrit à cet
abonnement là et donc en fait on arrive
à se poser la question de se dire
qu'elles sont en fait est ce que
j'achète un produit je le possède
pour quelles raisons l'ont fait et il
existe en fait j'ai noté deux types il
ya les produits que l'on achète pour
usage pour les utiliser il nous ils nous
sont utiles et puis il ya des produits
qui existent pour transmettre
alors après à vous de voir la part qu'il
faut faire entre les objets les produits
qui sont à transmettre envie transmettre
c'est à des enfants à nos enfants à
dallas famille et à des gens ou des
objets qui sont simplement là pour pour
être utile et donc cela en fait ça ça
nous amène sur tout ce qui l économie du
partage c'est à dire ai-je besoin en
fait de posséder pour l'utiliser est-ce
que et l'utilisation que j'en fais est
ce qu'elle est constante sur cet objet
là où en fait jean dispose genre je
l'utilisé que vraiment très peu tout
comme moi c'est le parti que j'ai pris
j'ai pas de voiture ça nous sert j'en
avais une fête avant d'arriver sur paris
et puis au fur et à mesure de ma
réflexion l'abrasion moi je l'utilisé
pas forcément beaucoup
elle me coûter cher en entretien et en
maintenance et donc pourquoi pas
disposer de prendre un abonnement et
avoir soit chez des loueurs d'avoir des
on peut avoir des il ya des abonnements
qui existent pour pouvoir disposer à
tout moment d'une voiture ou simplement
le theule autolib qui existent ou le
vélib pour disposer d'un vélo on n'a pas
besoin de posséder pour l'utiliser donc
c'est une vraie réflexion qu'on peut
qu'on peut avoir sur ces sujets là est
de se dire mince et c'est de partager
avec d'autres ou de moins d'utiliser un
produit ou un service vraiment quand on
en a on en a besoin et le reste du temps
on le laisse ce soin à d'autres ou à une
entreprise qui gère ça
ah ça en fait on s'aperçoit qu'il y a un
souhait de consommer mieux
par exemple vous pouvez très bien
souscrire un abonnement auprès d'un
maraîcher pour pourvoir en fait disposé
de son petit panier de fruits et légumes
est en fait par chaque semaine vous
pouvez disposer de ce petit panier est
en fait ce qu'il veut ce qui se passe
c'est que par cet engagement que vous
faites
de l'autre côté en fait le producteur il
peut calibrer sa production et ne plus
avoir 50% de sa production 30% de sa
production qui part à la benne parce qu
en fait personne en fait les hd où il ya
eu peut-être un petit défaut qui était
pas bien et tout ça mais en tout cas ils
perdent ça lui permet de calibrer en
même temps ce que ça lui permet cette
pouvoir de dire eh bien j'ai moins de
clients à les contacter à rencontrer je
vais tout simplement en fait maintenant
que j'ai mon volume d'abonnés pouvoir me
dégager du temps et me concentrer sur
mes produits ou des services
complémentaires - dans mon petit panier
il me met des recettes de cuisine et ça
c'est un service complémentaire qu'on va
pas forcément trouver ailleurs dans un
supermarché ou avoir scellé du métal et
et fillon répond à vue et en est on part
il ya les coffrets aussi qui existent
par abonnement on par exemple pour mon
cas je suis abonné à des services qui
livrent deux à trois bouteilles de vin
par par mois et pour lesquels en fait du
fait qu on assure qu'on va qu'on a pris
un abonnement et qu'on va pourvoir ont
fait souscrire sur le long terme ils
vont ils vont pouvoir en fait fournir
des petits des petits journaux dans
lesquels ils vont pouvoir expliquer
comment déguster tel et tel vin ou après
il ya des coffres acquise pour pour de
la bière et puis après il ya tout plein
de copains qui existe qui vont pour
mettre en fait de fournir des services
complémentaires ont fait ce que je
trouve intéressant dans la bonne chose
c'est que ça permet de faire naître des
nouveaux modèles et on en a bien besoin
en ce moment qui permettent aussi de
pouvoir d'un côté nous faire économiser
du temps
nous faire véhiculer des valeurs
par exemple tout ce qui touche en fait à
l'économie du partage et donc vous est
ce que ce que j'aimerais en fait à la
fin de cette présentation est plus tard
quand vous allez faire vos prochains
achats vous êtes en passe de faire une
prochain achat c'est plutôt de se dire
est ce qui n'existe pas un service
d'abonnement à qui me permettrait
d'accéder à ce service ou à cet objet là
est ce que j'ai vraiment besoin
d'acheter ce service là pour l'utiliser
deux ou trois fois et de réfléchir et si
on fait vous trouvez pas le jeu ce
service là c'est peut-être une
opportunité en fait de le créer de créer
une entreprise qui doit pourvoir ont
fait l'opérer je vous remercie